this is the Houthi defense minister in a
command center planning to launch an
attack inside Saudi Arabia and
coordinating with his forces on the
ground according to the Houthi spokesman
it happened on August 25th and lasted
for 72 hours
specialized infantry units at the
frontline cordoned a large number of the
aggressors personnel in najran as they
managed to set up ambushes as per the
plan our forces opened a way to allow
the aggressive personnel to step into
the ambush
the Houthis claimed more than 500 people
were killed and at least 2,000 captured
some of them were wearing uniforms like
this with the Saudi National Guard logo
but many of these prisoners of war are
what the Houthis are calling yemeni
nationals who've been lured and
disillusioned by saudi arabia to fight
against the Houthis also on display
these armored vehicles which the Houthis
say belonged to the Saudi military
al-maliki had the Emilia and Nadia
specialized units cut off the rear
supply line of the enemy from the east
and the West
after that the cordon was sealed around
this personnel from all sides the
infantry units turned the ambush into an
all-out offensive the Houthis have also
made several other statements in this
video
none of which al Jazeera can
independently verify meanwhile Saudi
officials have not responded to this
video or the claims made by the Houthis
but for now this appears to be more
evidence that this conflict is likely to
pose further challenges for Yemen and
the region dorsa jabari al Jazeera